inside sagal's Parliament opposition MPS
are removed by police in riot gear some
shout democracy is under attack as they
are pushed out they had refused to sign
a bill to delay the election and extend
the president's time in power Security
Forces using tactics from the street
inside the National Assembly against
elected members of parliament the motion
to delay the election by 9 months
effectively extending the president's
mandate is passed nearly unanimously
after hours of heated
debate what has just been voted is
unprecedented in sagal's history it's a
constitutional coup because article 103
of the Constitution says clearly the
Mandate of the head of States cannot be
extended or
revised from the suburbs to the edge of
parliament protests are getting louder
and coming closer to the presidential
Palace the government has restricted
mobile internet access some local media
Outlets have have been taken off air
authorities say they are stopping the
spread of hateful and divisive content
rice groups say it's a violation of
fundamental rights two presidential
candidates are appealing to the
Constitutional Council to
intervene the Constitutional Council has
a responsibility to take decisions that
will bring calm to the country and save
our nation from this somber period which
is really an insult to the sagales
people the police intervene
preventing the candidates from Talking
salul says the elections were cancelled
because members of that Council which is
meant to draw the list of candidates are
suspected of taking bribes he says the
electoral process has lost credibility
and a delay will allow time to rebuild
trust in the country's institutions the
President says this bill is a way to
clean up democracy in this country he is
now calling for national dialogue and
he's hoping that this will quell anger
on the streets but there is growing
resentment amongst many salies that feel
that they have been robbed of the
opportunity to have their say on who
gets to govern this country Nicholas
Hawk Al jazer
darar make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer